shout out to my man kurt cobain's just
tore [__] up and mesa hey the ladies was
feeling you mean
oh man
hey that [__] was crazy man appreciate
it that [__] was insane you wouldn't
have to sing that nah they knew it it
was crazy yeah that's what afraid it was
acapella and everything what yeah man
hey let's talk about having this single
uh it's been number one on rhythmic
radio for like seven weeks something
like that how's it feel man
regular you know it feels regular yeah i
don't feel like
i'm not i don't know i'm just typing
dude i try to tell myself when i achieve
something just keep on going so yeah i
just want to have on to the next one
number one
album just you know i feel like record
sales is really just slacking right now
like that i want to be
one of the people that you've been when
i haven't come up with all right you
know saying the game is back you know
right so i want to be one like jake
yeah of course selling like that
yeah i want to contribute just like that
it seems like you got quite the call
following and it's always good when when
most you're following it seems the
ladies man like we were saying the
ladies because girls buy records girls
got more money to do they do
and they buy the records bro yes most
definitely indeed man hey i wanted to
talk to you about uh your basketball
history man yeah i hear you're quite the
baller yeah what is your your history
how how much ball did you play coming up
i played all through high school yes you
know
i was like i was just mounting dudes
like you got a ball in your neck yeah i
never got to that point where i could
play where i want to play when i was a
senior yeah i was like five feet tall
you know when i finally got a varsity on
the scene and then my point guard yeah
man was killing us and i was on the
second string but we had a game we
played the first ring through on my back
they already had like 35 points
next day i broke my foot and then
he said thanks for not dropping the
footage you know what is that i don't
know i'm just waiting for my mixtape to
come out so i need a lot of footage
yeah or closer to his album embarrass
him when he's like
that's what's up man hey uh another
thing i want to talk to you about um of
course when new artists come out
it's always uh
you know it's always easy to compare new
artists to other artists that are on it
and you know the first time i heard you
i heard uh i heard kind of a little bit
of drake you know what i'm saying i
didn't hear houston yeah
how do you accept like you know those
comparisons because i know sometimes
people don't take comparison as well
because yeah but to me it's just like
i'm just starting you know what i'm
saying
yeah i'm just starting and this is just
like
drake don't sound like he's not when he
first started first that's true come
back season yeah true
like nobody rains nobody sounds the way
they sound she's like
you always get something from something
yeah they do they do put some on their
swag so like i said eight times yes you
are so this [__] that rap playing has
been around since
you know about uh pepsi you know what i
said pimp c giro bingo like that's
always been there like even trey like a
millionaire
singing and rapping
melodies laid back style that's
something
they're super underrated
um
in your opinion man this is going to be
a tough question but who are your top
three
of all time houston rappers
h-town strickler
can you see
well thanks for answering that question
a lot of artists [__] man they won't
answer they'll be like ah man it's too
hard you know everybody else knows
yeah
hey when uh the drink of my cup uh joint
came out i know that there was like a j
cole remix that dropped and then he had
tweeted something
yeah what was that about all right what
happened was
labor reached out for that verse okay
what i'm saying but it was just during
my cup it's a 12. yeah so i think people
seem like 16. so he's had the whole he
he wanted the whole thing to be put out
the way he said yeah yeah
beefing over some [__] that i know like
that me i'll be pissed off as well yeah
we don't know this whole story because
we don't know each other so that's
[__] up again i feel like if anybody
should do when you do remixes or any
type of music like when i came into this
game i saw everything would be like
organic
especially when you got that that number
one single yeah and they're like who's
hot we need we need to put them on this
river
um
my cup which is you know pretty much
about sipping that lean yeah but really
it's about a [__] and drinking and the
lane is actually like you'll see uh
space jam you know that special water
yeah it's like the lane i need to get
the girl so well what i wanted to talk
to you about is uh you know there's been
some negative uh you know happenings
with with sarah we were with pepsi
passing and i know schoolboy cube
recently quit quit sipping um have you
experienced any any naked the negative
part of of of that particular uh habit
yeah
before you do anything like you're a
doctor if you do interviews with me from
a certain place or
anything like you sell church you have
to get the research you got to get your
roots right before you start that's what
it is yeah it was like whatever i did
with that sounds like people that's
where i was in front of my first one i
got to let [__] know where i'm
my partner told me about this year
nature you know i don't know [__] i'm
just going to do it
just trying to really build my brain and
get my momentum so you got a good job
sell like
10 20 40 000 units i'm trying to i'm
trying to handle my good i'm trying to
have my people not working
you got a mixtape drop in how soon
actually i just uh
what it is man we can't wait for that
second single congrats on all the
success
uh hey man i gotta think i you know when
when houston really had that resurgence
with mike jones and paul
i'm a big fan of houston
so it was kind of helpful to hear the
screwed up portions of drinking my cup
on the radio
it's crazy
so crazy i had a dj
work drinking my cup by itself now i
can't listen to [__]
so
you know what it is